in recent months and
years a decidedly High number of reports
of people's deaths that are
surprising now obviously there is
nothing new about this and I have used
the example of John Ritter the comedian
who died suddenly on the set of his
sitcom of ortic dissection I've
forgotten how many years ago that was
but it was long before there was
anything like Co in the world certainly
long before there was anything vaccine
like and so I used mRNA vaccine like
yeah right exactly mRNA vaccine or mRNA
vaccine as the case may be
um I use that because I know that if
John Ritter had died in
2022 it would have been very difficult
for people to except he's a Hollywood
guy he will have gotten uh Co vaccinated
um you know atic dissection he was a
healthy guy um yada y y people would
have concluded that it had been the
result of that technology and it
wouldn't have been because obviously he
died of it before that technology had
ever been
deployed so there's obviously lots of
deaths which if they happen in a
particular context people will see them
as the result of some new process but
because they happened before the
processes were there we can be certain
that we have we have a baseline of these
things and lots of people just simply
die but then there's a question of okay
you see a number of deaths of
people and the question is at what point
does the number in your circle imply
that some force is present that you
should be thinking about and this is now
become a problem because there are many
of us who have focused on the hazard of
the so-called covid vaccines and the
phenomenon apparently of sudden deaths
that seem to be
Downstream uh of these
shots but we we don't want to have a
confirmation bias where we view every
death as this because we weren't doing a
good job of paying attention to the
baseline or because we're now doing a
better job of paying attention to people
who have died uh as a result of uh
whatever cause you know we are now
tracking these things in a way that we
didn't track them before we worried
about this and so anyway I wanted to
provide
some um toolkit for how to think about
these things and Zach you want to show
this just these are some things that
showed up we're up here in the San Juan
Islands um you know just to show those
couple uh that I sent you this these
were just things that showed up uh on a
Facebook group here is a a local
herbalist who died uh Ryan drum uh show
the other one here's somebody I think I
had encountered a couple of times but I
didn't really know him he was a local
nature
photographer uh people were very sad
about his death the implication was that
it was unexpected now neither of these
are young men um they were clearly uh
older here's something that crossed my
feed this is uh David Ike's daughter
apparently
died at
48 now the question is what does one do
with all of this maybe we're seeing more
death because people are posting it more
maybe we see more death because the
circle that we are paying attention to
is larger I know that this is true in
many of our cases um just by virtue of
the way the internet works and the fact
that we accumulate a larger circle of
people that we follow we tend to follow
more people than we remove from our uh
followed list um so there are lots of
processes that could cause you to
encounter more deaths so you would have
the impression that people are uh dying
unexpectedly at a greater rate let's say
you've got a pattern like it seems to me
that people are dying unexpectedly at a
higher rate than I am used to and that
that seems to match a uh a change in our
Behavior the public health response to
co for example okay the problem is if
I'm stuck with my anecdotal encounter
with the world and this pattern and we
could do the same thing for the pattern
of uh violence in our cities then I have
no way of decisively answering the
question the only thing I can do is say
does the pattern continue to match the
does the pattern continue to anecdotally
match the uh predictions of the model I
have that there is something new and
dangerous loose in the world right so
what what I wanted to do now is show
what you do if you actually want to take
that anecdotal pattern and the
hypothesis that results from it and get
rigorous and if you would show there was
a excellent talk at The covid Summit in
Romania I'm not going to show you the
talk it's worth the 25 minutes or so to
watch it but this is uh Dennis rainc
Court that's what it looked like in the
auditorium um and and Dennis Rancourt is
a physicist who has gone and analyzed
the all cause mortality data from around
the world he's looked at countries
different countries he's looked at very
different time scales um and so here
take a look this is the pattern of all
cause
mortality um by month over a 100 years
70 but okay yep um what you'll
see is a pattern of spikes and troughs
that your mind will correctly register
as highly regular now what that highly
regular pattern is is um an oscillation
of seasons and for reasons that rain
Court correctly points out are not fully
understood there is an increasing all
cause mortality that means we don't care
what you died of the question is we just
count deaths and we look at the pattern
people tend to die in the winter and
they tend to die much less in the summer
and the exact reason for that is not
perfectly
understood um now I would argue that
the
um the likely explanation for this is
somewhere in the neighborhood
of we all have some proximity to death
at every moment a force with which the
grave pulls at us that force is quite
strong in the first year of
life it decreases radically over that
year if you survive to one year of age
that Force pulling you towards the grave
tends to be flat until you reach the age
of sexual maturity at which point it
begins to very gradually and then with
an accelerating pattern incre until it's
quite precipitous late in life and then
there is arguably a plateau largely due
to what is likely a decrease in your
risk of cancer if you live through the
period in which cancer has
skyrocketed but in any case interesting
that the data if you plot it out reveal
this highly regular pattern and as
predicted this is Northern Hemisphere
this is France data you're looking at
here um very interesting and of course
necessary that it' be this way if we
look at the southern hemisphere where
the um pattern of seasons is inverted
then the pattern of spikes and troughs
is inverted as it would have to be
otherwise the explanation would be
falsified by it um so anyway that's what
the general pattern looks
like um can you show the next
graph I don't know what you mean by that
okay so I maybe I didn't capture the
other graph you want to show his
bulleted list then oh yes so here is the
upshot from this
extremely uh carefully done research and
I want to call your
attention um
to especially number five uh number four
on this list 17 million vaccine deaths
worldwide to the present um uh plus or
minus half a million that is an
incredibly High number now of course the
number of inoculation ations given uh
was staggering you know obviously we're
not just talking about billions of
people who were inoculated but many of
them inoculated multiple times elsewhere
in this talk and again I encourage you
to go look at it he points out that the
risk goes up Rather precipitously with
the number of doses you've had uh
becoming quite high at um at the fourth
dose interesting um I wasn't there I
haven't seen the talk um but the fifth
point on this list fatal toxicity is
exponential with age with the risk of
death doubling every 45 years of age um
that is not countered to but is the um
the opposite direction of what we have
talked about anecdotally what what it
seems to be the case not with regard to
fatality but Adverse Events wherein in
you know
2022 uh when we were talking about the
insanity of giving these vaccines to
young people um the point was that covid
is simultaneously a disease that does
not affect the young very much and these
vaccines seem to produce a greater
number of Adverse Events in the young
now we did not we never said that it
tends to kill the young more right um
but that the the myocarditis and
pericarditis specifically in young men
and um potentially um menstrual and
pregnancy issues in young women um you
know just because that's that's a young
woman's situation um but is is more of
an issue um in youth uh whereas he's
finding fatal toxicity uh increasing
with age so I wanted to actually
navigate that a little bit yeah um and
this I'm drawing from the research that
I did uh back when I was doing the tiir
work and deeply embedded in the the
evidence surrounding syence yeah now
inessence which begins at the age of
first reprodu uction or average age of
first reproduction for your species and
continues to uh to accelerate through
life with additional
years um that
process
is the um it is the empirical
description of the vulnerability that I
was just describing the force that is
pulling you towards the grave now on
your 20th birthday the force that is
pulling you towards the grave is so weak
now if you're a male you may be inclined
to risky behaviors and we can argue
about what that pattern is but from the
point of view of the failure of your
biological systems at a critical level
that would cause you to Die the force is
extremely weak at 20 especially in the
prior world before all of the novel
influences you know you might now be a
20-year-old with a metabolic disease
that would make you much more vulnerable
but historically speaking you would have
had a very low um degree of decrepitude
at 20 right maybe only a few years and
accelerating at a very low rate and as
you get older the degree to which your
systems are compromised by this goes up
and up and up and so if you imagine as
Dr ranc Court points out in his talk if
you imagine that the MRNA vaccines
function as a toxin and I'm not sure
that's exactly the right description
they are toxic but they are more than
that because of the way they interact
with the immune system but um yeah
they're not inert yeah they they
are they are a uh complex toxin the tox
keeps on giving indeed um but anyway the
point is if you imagine that every
person that you encounter is if if you
could look above their heads and there
was a number that indicated the degree
to which the grave was pulling on them
then
you would say well if you were to
administer a toxin broadly across all of
them some of them that number at which
the grave is pulling towards them is so
high that it won't take very much right
now that's the same thing that we likely
see in the seasonal pattern right if
you're very very close to death then you
know the insults that come along with
winter right might be enough to do it if
you're very healthy and young then it's
not going to and so in any case I think
in part we are
um we
are hampered in our ability to
understand what's going on because death
is such a focus and the problem is death
is a binary
thing whereas damage is not right so to
the extent that something damaging has
been released on the public and that
that is measurable in the death of
people who were close enough in
proximity to the grave that it pushed
them over the edge right and it will
very rarely get somebody who's perfectly
healthy and it will very frequently get
people who were headed that direction
anyway and um you know so we need we
need a better toolkit to think about
these things but my larger point is if
you anecdotally think that you're seeing
a pattern you're being denied
information on what that pattern is
you're not allowed to know what these
people died of therefore if you start
saying oh it's another died suddenly and
somebody says aha this person was sick
for 7 years right it's not had died
suddenly as a result of these
inoculations because they were sick long
before these inoculations had ever been
given to anybody okay you win but um but
if you were interested in figuring out
okay to what degree were these things
causing that harm is the fact that I
seem to be seeing not only anomalies in
the number of people who seem to be
dying but also
tragically the number of people people
who seem to be reporting
um
serious disruptions of of pregnancy yeah
right so you know again do they happen
under normal circumstances of course
probably some of that normally happening
during normal circumstances is actually
the result of other novel phenomena
toxins in the environment and who knows
you know metabolic diseases whatever the
novel influences are and then there
would be in an ancestral environment
that was free of all the novel
influences presumably a very tiny rate
of those things why in large measure
because the body is built to um not
invest in projects that are fatally
compromised and so there is a very high
rate of um spontaneous abortion which
presumably is a result of the fact that
the body is uh looking at a pregnancy
that's underway and deciding whether
it's a good enough bet to continue to
invest in it um so anyway there are
elegant systems in the body they're
disrupted by novelty the fact that the
public health campaign appears to have
created a
huge um quantity of excess death
something like 17 million people
globally and that's not even the cost of
the public health campaign that is the
uh apparent
vaccine induced deaths to date so think
about in light of the model we've just
put forward think about what that
actually implies if the if damage was
done by these inoculations to uh a large
fraction of the people who received them
and some small fraction of those people
were being pulled towards the grave uh
at a strong enough level that they
disappeared and they ended up in our
statistics then the question question is
how many years of life are people
actually being robbed of what's the net
effect and what is the total number of
excess deaths that will ultimately be
attributable to this um to this public
health campaign so all of those things
are interesting in addition to the
deaths that were the result of other
interventions that were uh that were
mandated you know ventil ventilators and
then there's the question even more
difficult question this one I I don't
exactly know how you study it but
there's the question
of given the treatments that turn out to
work that were denied to people yeah in
order presumably to get them to accept
these um these
inoculations what would the number of
excess deaths have been how much lower
would the excess mortality rate B uh had
uh drugs like icin and hydroxy
chloroquin
been administered more freely absolutely
which is affected by something that
raint says um in the beginning of his
talk which is um that you actually do
not see a spike of excess deaths um that
are related to covid that they seem to
be related to um the measures that were
mandated in the aftermath of its
announcement right and this I
mean what did they get that vaccine to
us very very fast and uh had they been
able to put together a story in which
the vaccine arrived exactly coincident
with the virus then we would not have uh
the control group then we could not say
this is excess mortality from covid
which is to say oops 2020 basically
nothing and this is excess mortality uh
after uh the MRNA technology was
deployed um if those two things had
shown up at the same moment we couldn't
compare and all of this would be
attributed to the disease yep um all
right now
there's there's further road we can go
down but I think um this is maybe a good
place to to put this on pause for now
with the understanding that it what we
have done is we have taken the anecdotal
experience of a person who doesn't know
how to think about this we have talked
about um from that formulated a
hypothesis that then is in need of a
test and then the fact that that test
can actually come in the form of large
data sets that capture unambiguous
events like death and show us um that in
fact whether or not the specific deaths
that caused us to formulate that
hypothesis were caused by this exact
thing that they are completely
consistent with the idea that there is a
new force that it is a hazard that we
are justified in uh focusing our
attention on these deaths our morbid
curiosity in this case is a survival
Instinct MH that's it it's a survival
Instinct and that to deny you the
information that allows that survival
Instinct to gather appropriate
information is a crime in and of
[Music]
itself